- A student was given a piece of rope
and told to cut it into two equal pieces,
keep one piece, and pass the other piece
to the next student.
Each student was to repeat this process
until every student in the class
had exactly one piece of rope.
Which of the following
could be the fraction
of the original rope that
one of the students had?
So the key realization
here is that each student
is going to have--
The first student's going
to have half the rope,
and then each student after that's
going to have half of that.
So all of the possible fractions
are going to be powers of 2.
So one-half, one-half times 2,
one-half times one-half is one-fourth,
one-half to the third power is one-eighth,
one-half to the fourth
power is one-sixteenth.
And we could keep going,
but lucky for us we
already see the choice.
One-sixteenth.
Now, just to make that
a little bit clearer,
let's work it out a little bit more.
Just in case that seemed a little bit
too hand-wavey for you.
So the first student,
you have the whole rope,
cuts it in half and keeps half of it,
and hands that half--
So, they get to keep half,
and then hands the remaining half
to the next student.
So the next student has that half,
but then has to cut it in half.
And so that student is
going to be able to keep
what I just circled, one-fourth,
and then that's half of a half,
which is one-fourth.
And then hand that one-fourth over
to the next student.
The next student is going
to keep half of that,
which I just circled,
which is one-eighth.
And I think you get--
You see the general idea here.
This is one-half, this is one-fourth,
this is one-eighth.
One-half to the first power,
one-half to the second power,
one-half to the third power,
and you could keep on going.
And of course, one-half
to the fourth power
if we go one more step.
We go one more step,
so now you have one-eighth of a rope
and the student cuts it in half
and keeps half of it.
That's one-sixteenth right over there.
Which is what we actually picked.